five years ago Humanity quietly crossed
into a new era
a scientist walked on stage at the human
genome editing conference in Hong Kong
to reveal he'd modified the embryos of
twin girls before they were born he
changed a gene known to create
resistance to infection by HIV
scientists in the audience were shocked
and a near unanimous call was made to
Halt similar attempts illnesses like
sickle cell anemia cystic fibrosis and
Huntington's disease are inherited they
start as variations in genes the codes
in human DNA that tell bodies how to
make cells out of millions of letters of
code
just one can be out of place
and in some cases only one parent needs
to have a variant Gene to pass a serious
and rare condition to their children new
tools are available to edit the human
genome the most efficient so far is
crispr it finds cuts and replaces parts
of genes to deliver a new genetic code
to a target with great accuracy our
vision our dream is that there would be
basically a crispr cures Center
where
Physicians would see a child their the
child's DNA would get read and
professional geneticists would
understand what causes the disease and
then they would send that information
to the crispr cures group and they would
be like a rapid response team they would
just jump on it today genetic editing
therapies modify immune cells to
recognize cancer correct loss of vision
directly in the eye and seem to have
reversed sickle cell anemia by editing
the cells in bone marrow we want to
really pay attention as these
Technologies are being developed as
they're getting closer and closer to
Market about how we are considering the
populations at hand that have access or
don't have access to these Technologies
a human embryo contains a few cells that
become a whole person in theory these
could be edited to prevent a rare or
serious inherited disease from ever
starting
but no Studies have shown how an
embryonic edit would affect a person
throughout their life and as an embryo
develops into a fetus any changes would
be replicated too including in the cells
involved in reproduction and that would
allow human-made changes to be passed
down generation after generation with
unknown effects
the last time they met scientists in
ethicists said it was too soon to try
with new therapies coming online it
might also not be worth the risk Colin
Baker Al Jazeera